salut aujourd'hui je suis avec quelqu'un
de très particulier ici chez moi à ma
maison c'est tommy milliers c'est un
pote d'enfance un pote de primaires
c'est ça c'était un nouveau tu sais les
nouveaux de l'école primaire c'est un
nouveau tome iv ce qui nous a rejoint
ses mains c'est ça c'est mince end et il
ya quelques jours il m'a envoyé un petit
tweet en même temps est chaud paris on
se voit et grave je ne devais pas
mentaliser thomas je vais te faire un
tour de magie ça fait très longtemps que
j'ai pas fait de tour de magie sur sur
la chaîne avec un jeu de cartes est ce
qu'elles sont bien tout rouge
est ce que tu veut mélanger ce jeu tomic
est ce que tu me fais confiance ou pas
tu veux je suis sur scène pas faire
encore façon lemay qui mélangeait aucune
confiance
aucune terre que ça va faire plus de 20
ans fait qu'on s'est rencontré et il n'y
a pas la confiance
ouais mais je suis arrivé en tant que
petit nouveau quand même à l'école j'ai
subi des brimades
j'étais mal vu forcément tu prends une
carte celle qui te fait le plus envie le
prix du plaisir peu importe
par exemple mais quand on a une dans les
mains tu la feras tout le monde à la
caméra mais c'est vraiment une fois je
puisse la voir
c'est bon ou pas ouais
faut qu'on communique on semble opposer
le proposait la jda préjugés sur ton
veut un an
alors faut jamais pour tous regardent
même mélanger pour autre chose comme ça
peut même la perte on peut même mélanger
en profondeur c'est dieu lui-même
mélanger sans regarder si tu veux me
même mélanger comme ça situe là le
problème c'est qu'elle est vraiment
perdu j'ai aussi un peu en retrait mais
sur les mélanges mais c'est pas grave
j'ai cette capacité à retrouver les
cartes tout l'intérêt d'un tour
d'ailleurs si je pose le jeu là on le
voit oui c'est formidable alors par
contre il faut m'aider en bien compte
que je n'ai pas de miracle faut m'aider
à retrouver la carte pour ça j'ai
déplacé cinq par cinq et toutes les cinq
car je demanderai si elle est passée et
tout les 5 arte vous dira non non mon
jusqu'au moment où tu me diras à vous
dire ça va c'est clair là par exemple
j'ai le set de coeur g5 de carouge hélas
de 13,2 13g l'as de pique
est ce qu'elle est passée je serai après
allait passer au bafa
madame sa part que ce serait une
première dans cette qpc bondi la veille
à donges est un test pour vérifier alors
on va faire le test vaillante qui tient
les 5 cartes comme ça fermement et
jeuland a élevé une et une seule du bout
des doigts
si c'est la tienne c'est celle ci que je
sortirai est-ce que c'est celle ci vous
ne voyez pas la carte parce que c'est
une carte invisible parce que figurez
vous que quand je fais un tour de magie
se donne les moyens c'est un gros tour
chacun d'accord oui on va dire que oui
alors quoi c'est du trash lacet sa
longueur
voyez du trèfle ou pas autant deuxième
test les cartes invisibles ils ont une
tendance comme ça elle flotte légèrement
en l'air ils ont du mal à retomber
tu vois le reste juste comme ça et à ce
moment précis à ce moment précis en
général les gens se disent que je
raconte n'importe quoi
j'ai la preuve quand même de te le
prouver qu'il est car j'ai l'impression
qu'ils racontent n'importe quoi depuis
le novembre à nous tous et à 5/4 point
une carie l'essence étant resté combien
m ce mec a des capacités en calcul
contre les k23 et ce qui est encore la
carte de dans ce cas les raisins terium
bordelais non mais c'est bon désire
garder un allié pas non parce qu'elle
est là en train de flotter ici en l'air
tu vois par contre je peux la faire
réapparaître située à antibes ou une
pichenette et ça lui permet de tomber
alors des fois oui des principaux toile
un petit peu et d'atterrir dans le jeu
pas sur le jeu dans le jeu
regarde on voit bien la caméra d'or je
retourne ma première c'est rien ça n'est
pas elle non non non c'est une bd
par contre si tu es talent le jeu
complètement désuni talbot et elle le
sera ensuite amusé à la mettre en oeuvre
bah je pense qu'elle est tombée à
l'envers ça depuis tout à l'heure mais
je pense qu'elle est tombée à l'envers
et en plein milieu du jeu et but à tête
je pense que c'est hélas de 13 merci de
me lier alors tommy millet il a pas
d'actu parce que son à cuba c'est sa vie
personnelle évidemment ma fille et sa
vie elle est privée mais je vous
raconterai dans les commentaires mais
qu'il a des dossiers sur moi deux autres
de faire le gros dos innocence merci
beaucoup d'avoir subi cette vidéo pensez
à laisser un petit pouce en l'air si ce
tour là où vous vous écoutez moi je
voulais pas vous le dire mais
apparemment si pour vous plaît merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour le
prochain mortal blog ciao